[Musique]
un nouveau numéro du 7-8 dossier préparé
par la rédaction de tv et soixante dix
huit ce mois ci nous allons nous pencher
sur les fêtes de fin d'année et vous
donner quelques idées de cadeau 100%
local le département ne manque pas de
richesses pour décorer s'habiller
déguster ou encore s'amuser la sélection
de nos équipes à suivre au cours du
prochain quart d'heure avec tout d'abord
est de la bière artisanale brassée à
bois d'arcy et puis un indémodable qui a
su se renouveler au fil du temps à la
toile de jouy
[Musique]
pour fabriquer sa bière tout commence
avec une céréale le malt
c'est vraiment ce qui va donner notre
base de céréales ce qui va donner la
couleur de notre bière ce qui va donner
le profil gustatif de notre de notre
bière et au final c'est aussi ce qui va
créer du sucre ou ce qui va nous créer
ce que va nous créer l'alcool chez
oakbrook hing la brasserie artisanale
monté par une bande de trois copains à
bois d'arcy il ya trois ans on utilise
un panel d'une quinzaine de malte
différents qui sont concassés dans ce
moulin fois qu'on a sélectionné notre
notre grand con la concassée
l'idée c'est de faire venir tout le
grain qu'on a stocké là bas jusqu'à
cette cuve ici qui est notre cube
d'empotage
donc c'est ici où on va réellement
brasser les graines sont mélangés à de
l'eau chaude à 65 degrés celsius pendant
une heure et demie lorsque l'infusion
est terminée le rinçage commence pour
s'assurer que tous les grains soit entré
en contact avec le liquide avant de
passer à l'émulation après filtration
une fois qu'on a notre note liquide qui
est rentré en ébullition on va commencer
à faire nos premiers houblonnage sachant
que les houblons plus on va les utiliser
tôt pendant cette ébullition et plus
vont donner de l'amertume après avoir
brillé pendant une heure et demie le
liquide est stérile et il faut utiliser
un refroidisseur pour faire baisser sa
température
une fois qu'on l'a refroidi on vient
positionner note liquide à l'intérieur
de ces de ces cubes que vous avez
derrière derrière moi qu'ils sont des
fermenteurs
et une fois tout notre note liquide a
été refroidie qu'il est rentré à
l'intérieur de ce qu à 20 degrés on va
ainsi miné la bière c'est à dire qu'on
va lui
ajoutez des levures l'éleveur agit
cependant cette étape de fermentation
leur travail et de manger le sucre créé
l'alcool et le co2 qui rendra la bière
pétillante l'accusent passe ensuite de
20 à 0 degrés pour la dernière étape de
garde au froid donc en gros pour
fabriquer une bière on va avoir une
journée de fabrication une semaine de
fermentation et 3 semaines 2
de garde ce qui fait une tu vas les
monopolisé pendant à peu près un mois
une fois qu'elle a été elle a été brassé
chez o clock le brassage se fait deux à
trois fois par semaine en fonction des
cuves disponible pour varier les
plaisirs
les 3 brasseurs développe aussi une
gamme de bières vieilli en barriques
pour nous l'idée c'est pas d'acheter des
barriques neuves c'est d'acheter des
barriques qui ont déjà servi qui ont
déjà une histoire et de profiter de
l'histoire de ces barriques ici sont
stockés 40 baril qui vont faire leur
travail pendant six mois un nom pour des
bières aux arrière-goût d'alcool plus
fort les biarrots clock sont distribués
dans des bars et des revendeurs
indépendants en france et en europe mais
aussi dans leurs propres boutiques avec
une gamme de 12 à 15 bières différentes
qui varie chaque semaine la première
année on était même un peu surpris que
la bière était réellement
quelque chose qu'on pouvait qu'on
pouvait offrir à noël cette année ils
ont même développé un calendrier de
l'avent et une gamme à offrir et nous ce
qu'on propose pour pour noël c'est un
petit pack 2 un petit pack bébéar 2 avec
six bouteilles dans lequel vous avez les
cinq best seller de la brasserie qui est
complété par notre panneau de bière de
noël note christmas day et qui emballée
dans un paquet cadeau avec le descriptif
de toutes nos de toutes nos bières la
france est le troisième pays européen en
nombre de brasseries derrière
l'allemagne et le royaume uni
[Musique]
elle est la création d'un homme
oberkampf qui la fabrique à partir de
1760 à jouy en josas la toile de jouy
est apprécié à l'époque pour sa grande
qualité et la précision de ses dessins
le tissu est très vite prisé par la
bourgeoisie et la noblesse française
le succès de la toile de jouy tient à la
proximité de jouy en josas avec le
château de versailles
christophe et des power qui ont fait
était un visionnaire tendant
les motifs et d'un point de vue créatif
que dans sa gestion industrielle de la
manufacture la cour qui étaient
effectivement à proximité raffoler de sa
production si aujourd'hui l'indienne ne
se fabriquent plus dans sa ville
d'origine ces motifs célèbre se décline
en de nombreux produits dérivés au sein
du musée de la toile de jouy une
boutique où l'on peut trouver chaussures
bijoux trousse ou encore de la vaisselle
les plateaux qui ont été fait cette
année dans un motif bengale et ce choix
était fait surtout pour les couleurs que
manuel canovas utilise donc dans un ton
dans les tons aubergines nous avons
aussi une autre collection d'école qui a
été fait dans un motif dont qui a été
pris dans les fonds muséal dans le motif
de l'offrande à l'amour
donc nous avons quatre coloris qui ont
été fait cette année donc dans ce rouge
basque
un rose pompe et un vert de gris à
chaque saison sa collection pour
l'automne hiver le produit phare cette
année c'est une marinière créé en
partenariat avec la marque armor lux un
vêtement fabriqué à l'occasion de
l'exposition sur le peintre franco
japonais fujita qui se tient en ce
moment au musée de la toile de jouy
nous avons repris donc le motif
de l'art d'aimer que vous jugez pas
utiliser énormément dans ses oeuvres et
nous avons décidé de reprendre le bateau
donc un petit sinagot qui a été mise
dans les
dans les coudes hier
des marinières deux marques sont
disponibles dans la boutique collection
et création du musée de la toile de jouy
et pour panser ses produits
l'inspiration ne manquent pas au musée
qui possède un fonds de 10000 pièces de
toile de jouy de beignets effectivement
dans tous ces dessins je m'en lasse pas
je trouve toujours des choses nouvelles
c'est d'une richesse incroyable
moi ce que j'aime aussi beaucoup faire
c'est justement retravaillé tous les
motifs que nous avons nous dans les
réserves notamment les empreintes aussi
des choses fabuleuses
donc ça je décline avec sabre énormément
de papeterie aussi dans la boutique il y
en a pour tous les goûts et pour toutes
les bourses compter de 3 à 200 euros
pour ses produits au motif de la toile
venue de jouy en josas
[Musique]
et si au pied du sapin le père noël
déposer des sacs en tissu ou des
pochettes des produits artisanaux en
série très limitée
la créatrice nathalie de la ville et on
multiplie les marchés de noël les
marchés de noël me permettent de
rencontrer mes clientes d'aller
face
au public d'avoir les remontées
d'informations et puis des réactions de
d'éventuels clients sur mes produits
donc c'est à la fois moteur et c'est
assez satisfaisant
bienvenue dans mon atelier donc c'est le
sous sol de ma maison
un atelier versailles est lancée en 2013
nathalie de la ville et on y crée exposé
sur rendez vous depuis cinq ans près de
4000 pièces ont vu le jour
nathalie utilise sa première aiguille à
l'âge de 8 ans tout est fait main tout
est fait chaque pièce sort de l'atelier
sort d'ici je suis la seule à coudre
donc toutes les pochettes c'est moi qui
les ai faites du motif au tissu la
versaillaise pense chaque détail un sac
lui demande cinq heures de travail
elle crée également pochette et
accessoires de mode pour les bijoux
c'est une affaire de famille les bijoux
se sont développés parce que ma fille
aînée s'est prise d'affection pour les
perles et s'est mise à plein d'idées
donc elle s'est mise à développer cette
activité là aussi est comment dire à
partir de janvier elle va passer autant
entrepreneurs de façon à pouvoir devenir
mon fournisseur
nathalie de la ville et on propose ses
produits essentiellement aux ventes
privées par les réseaux sociaux et le
bouche à oreille
ses créations sont envoyés dans toute la
france et à l'étranger
je peux m'adapter aux besoins de la
cliente c'est à dire que si elle veut un
sac plus grand plus petit des ans plus
grande
quelque chose qui soit plutôt porté
épaule cette année j'ai fait surtout des
portes épaules pour pour l'hiver parce
que on m'avait dit voilà on aimerait
bien pouvoir le mettre sur nos manteaux
regardez quelques produits sont aussi
disponibles dans une boutique à
versailles nathalie il propose une
cinquantaine de créations
c'est très important d'être en boutique
en plus des marchés
comment dire qu'ils sont relativement
saisonniers parce que
les événements ont lieu en général en
fin d'année ou au moment de mars avril
mai juin
ça me permet d'avoir la possibilité de
rencontrer aussi des gens ailleurs que
chez moi je peux pas ouvrir l'atelier
non plus à tout le monde ça me permet de
m'inscrire dans
dans un univers puisque françois ce
travail par par univers tout et on n'a
pas de l'espace particulièrement dédié
on est un peu partout dans la boutique
des créations dans une large palette de
couleurs pour se faire plaisir hein ça
coûte entre 15 et 70 euros pour les
boucles d'oreilles compter de 12 à 45
euros
[Musique]
voilà pour cet aperçu des produits
locaux nous allons voir à présent qu'il
est aussi possible d'embellir sa
décoration de table et même de créer des
cartes de voeux à la mode yvelinoise
[Musique]
à l'espace jacqueline auriol des
clayes-sous-bois les petites mains
s'affairent pour confectionner un cadeau
et pas n'importe lequel puisqu'il est
fait main les participantes s'attaque à
une composition florale de quoi égayer
ses tables de fêtes de zama reggae des
des boules de ou du gypsophile du
branchage de noël des bâtons de cannelle
des boules des rondelles de d'orange et
de pommes
j'adore ça j'adore tout ce qui est
loisirs créatifs
cet atelier était dirigée par une
fleuriste de villepreux qui veille à
prendre des fleurs de saison ce sont des
compositions de noël faites à base
d'amaryllis une fleur de saison une
fleurs à bulbes donc là ce sont des
amaryllis couper que l'on pique dans de
la mousse et après que l'on agrémentent
avec des pleins de décorations de noël
du sapin des petites boules
des des fleurs fraîches également de
lézian tue son ami
et on a mis également après plein de
petits sujets le fait main est loin
d'être dépassé un autre atelier cartes
de voeux en scrapbooking étaient
proposées la grande banque veut comme ça
la toute petite de 2 cm de large
elle va être ici et là cette partie là
le bout on va le coller sur la bande
le matériel était mis à disposition
ainsi que le savoir faire de chacune
une fois qu'on a le matériel c'est
d'abord d'avoir un papier de fond style
papier canson un papier de déco et puis
d embellissement
après les étapes techniques place à la
décoration papier ruban stickers les
créatrices avait tout cela disposition
pour laisser cours à leur imagination
c'est du plaisir
sabran et puis ça passe le temps et puis
et puis pu voir ont pu voir comment on
fait ça s'écarte créer sa propre carte
de ses mains permet un cadeau
personnalisé
il ya le plaisir de faire il ya le
plaisir d'offrir parce que je sais que
les gens auxquels j'offre des gens
voient des cas les gardent donc ça déjà
ça m'a fait plaisir
comptez entre une à trois heures pour
concevoir sa carton scrapbooking enfin
terminée les participantes étaient ravis
je suis fier tout simplement
ces deux ateliers met en évidence une
des valeurs de noël le partage avec ses
proches
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce sept huit dossiers on
se retrouve en janvier nous parlerons du
travail des associations solidaires
pendant cette période hivernale
l'information locale est à retrouver à
chaque jour sur tv elle 60,18 excellente
fête
[Musique]